We love opening and reading all of your mail.
And I can't wait to get to your letters,
but first let's celebrate our zip code of the day.
It's 55427 Minneapolis, Minnesota,
home of our affiliate station KARE 11,
and home of the Minneapolis Skyway,
the longest continuous skyway system in the world,
spanning 69 downtown blocks!
In 2012, Minneapolis celebrated
the first internet cat video festival
at the Walker Art Center with more than 10,000 attendees.
Minneapolis, Minnesota, we would love to hear from you.
And please, we want you to know from our show
that we acknowledge you're the epicenter
of news and demand for change in our country.
So we would love to have any exchange with you possible.
(audience applauding)
Now to our first letter.
Okie dokie.
Okay.
"Dear Drew, after being an art teacher for 35 years,
I found a second career as the activity director
at Dowling Gardens in Sparkill, New York.
Our mission is to provide a safe, affordable,
caring housing community for seniors,
and due to the current pandemic,
all of our activities have to be outside.
I wonder if Jonah would like to donate
one of his crocheted coverlets to one of our residents
as a bingo prize!" from Beth in Sparkill, New York.
All right, it turns out that our producers spoke with Jonah,
and he was so happy to help that he is donating 10
of his beautiful creations!
(audience applauding)
Look at this big beautiful basket that Jonah did!
Oh, this is so gorgeous.
Look at these.
Oh, Beth, I hope this is what you were thinking.
Woo!
Thank you, Jonah.
Thank you so much.
(audience applauding)
Oh Jonah, you're just the best.
Okay, ow, ow, ow, turns out don't cross your legs
and then roll on in.
Okay, next letter, all righty.
"Hi Drew, I'm a stationary note card jewelry designer,
and it's wonderful to see the art of letter writing
making a comeback.
Here's your very own personalized stationary.
If you love it, I'd be thrilled
if you could give a shout out to our little boutique,
RooBarb Studios in Ohio.
Like all small businesses today,
we could use a little boost."
Jody, Findlay, Ohio.
Is there stationary?
Oh, there is!
Oh my goodness.
Aw! I love it!
(audience laughs)
Oh gosh.
Oh, this is gorgeous.
Thank you, Jody.
This is amazing.
(audience applauding)
Stationary with my name on it!
Thank you! Thank you, Jody.
(audience applauding)
I have to tell you, you sent this to the right place
because I love being a supporter of small businesses,
and I'll do better than a shout out.
We're gonna feature you in our Little Yellow Book
(audience applauding)
as well
as in our small business gift guide,
so thank you very much for your most personal gift
of personalized stationary.
Jody, from one lover of letters to another.
Okay, our last letter comes from Lance
in Jackson, California,
and he had actually written to us before,
asking about like a metal detector
because he wanted to go trace Howard Hughes
and have some adventures.
I don't know, let's find out what he's writing about now.
Okay, "Dear Drew,
I'm glad I wrote you, but I wished I asked
for world peace or something,
and I'm withdrawing my request for a metal detector."
Huh.
"I still plan on exploring Howard Hughes's old haunts,
and don't be surprised to see a package in the mail,
old school with halvsies like I promised.
I have four daughters, and my favorite nonprofit
is Tracey's Place of Hope where they provide a safe place
for girls in bad situations and nowhere else to go.
You do so many wonderful things for this world.
Please donate that money to them instead."
Lance in Jackson, California.
Oh, I think Lance we've just figured out
that you're the good person here,
and you're the inspiring one.
So we're gonna donate $1,000 that we were gonna send to you.
(audience applauding)
But I will double it, so we'll send $2,000 to that charity
with your name on it Lance, because this is all about you.
So anyone else out there, if you see anything,
want anything, advice, help,
maybe you want to share something, send me a joke.
A photo, requests, heartfelt funny stories,
whatever it is, please go to our address
at TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com/DearDrew.
I would love to get your letters.
Thank you so much, and on behalf of the show,
Beth, Jody, and Lance, thank you so much for your letters.
And here are my postcards to you.
All right, truly yours, Drew.
(upbeat music)